اهلا بكم الى مجاز لاهم الانباء انتهت
هدنه احاديه على متى موسكو في اوكرانيا
اكد خلال الجيش الروسي اطلاق النار على
الرغم من اعلانه تقدم قواته في مدينه
سردار الاستراتيجيه في تونس شرق البلاد من
جانبها قالت كيف ان المدينه مازال تحت
سيطرتها نافيه ووجود اي هدنه من الطرف
الروسيه واضافت ان الجيش الروسي وصل
عمليات القتاليه على محور باخ موت كما
اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ايضا قصف
وقال الرئيس الاوكراني يمارس لنسكي ان
الهدنه التي اعلنتها روسيا من طرف واحد لم
تكون سوا كذبه وفق تعبيره حيث واصلت
القوات الروسيه قصف الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ووصف الامين العام المساعد للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل حفيظه الازمه الحاليه في
تونس بالمعقده والمركبه واعتبر الامين
العام المساعد للاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل ان المسار السياسي الحاليه في
البلاد يمثل ارتدادا وتراجع عن مسار
الخامس والعشرين من يوليو بعد تفرد الرئيس
قيس سعيد بالحكم وقال ان الرئيس فرد
بصياغه قانون الانتخابي على مقاسه الغافيه
الاحزاب وكل المكونات السياسيه في البلاد
واضاف ان معالجه الحكومه للازمه
الاقتصاديه تعتمد على ما وصفه بالخيار
الليبرالي المتوحش وتحميل الطبقات الفقيره
والضعيفه كل فتى الازمه
هذا وقرر رئيسه التونسي وقيس السعيد اقاله
وزيره التجاره وتنميه الصادرات واوا
الصفاقس كذلك في بلاغ مقتضب لرئاسه
الجمهوريه دون ذكر الاسباب كما اتهم سعيد
بعد معارضيه بالتامل على امن الدوله
انتخب مجلس النواب الامريكي رئيسا جديدا
له بعد ازمه لم تشهد الولايات المتحده منذ
اكثر من 150 عاما وحصل مكان في عالم 216
صوت جمهوريا بعد ان قدم تنازلات لنواب
اقصى اليمين في حزبه
وتعاهد مكان في عقب انتخابه بتجاوز
الخلافات الداخليه بين الجمهوريين ومسائله
اداره بيض من جانبه ان الرئيس الامريكي
ودعه الى ممارسه السلطه بماسوليه
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك
انها حكومته مصممه على تخفيف الضغوط على
هيئه صحه الوطنيه في البلاد واكد سوناك في
تغريده على تويتر على ضمان تقديم رعايه
صحيه افضل للمرضى وعلى الالتزام بوعده
بخفض قوائم الانتظار للعمليات الجراحيه
غير العاجله
بدوره قال وزير الصحه البريطانيين العمل
جار لحل مشكله الضغوط الشديده على قطاع
الصحه
ختام الموجز في امان